I got to tell you when I look at what's
going on with the war and the conf
conflict and all this stuff as well as
what's going on with immigration
economics it feels intentional like it's
almost like Joe Biden the Democrats know
they're on the way out and if they can't
have it no one can and so they're just I
mean you look at Afghanistan how is that
anything but intentional you did not
have to abandon the BAM Air Force Base
in the middle of the night and not tell
the Afghan Security Forces I mean line
those things up let's say you decided
for some reason you had to abandon bam
okay well you tell the security forces
you don't do it in the middle of the
night you do it in controlled matter
let's say for some reason you couldn't
tell them you secure the materials and
the weapons and you get rid of them
before abandoning them to the Taliban
all of those things happening at once
now you look at the southern border with
the Biden Administration facilitating
illegal immigration it feels like he's
this Angry Kid the Democrats are playing
ball and they're like if I can't play
with the ball and they're going to
they're going to Chuck it over the fence
so that no one else can